today's show is sponsored by vincero
watches which is an american company
building
super premium wrist watches starting at
only about a hundred and fifty dollars
and they're giving you 15 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link underneath
this video today's show
also sponsored by blinkist which is the
app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist totally
free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman that link is underneath the
video as well
i hope everybody who had a long weekend
had a good long weekend we are back and
we must
dive right into it last week i laid out
for you
one framework for looking at the polling
that was relatively optimistic
and that framework essentially was joe
biden is beating trump nationally by
more than hillary was beating trump
nationally at this point
four years ago and joe biden is doing
quite well
in some important swing states today i
want to give you an alternative
perspective which gives us reason for
caution and for care
and it's a different framing of the same
data and in the states
likely to be decision makers
the reality is that joe biden is not
doing as well as hillary clinton was
doing at this point in 2016. now let me
be very clear as we get into this i'm
not telling you which framework is
correct
ultimately there's a reason why we do
the voting we don't just say these are
the polls
so that's the election the election is
the actual voting
and this is merely a point of
perspective
it can be at the same time true that joe
biden is doing better nationally and in
some states than hillary was
in 2016 while trailing in other states
relative to hillary it doesn't tell us
who will win only our voting tells us
who
who will win so the conclusion is of
course we have to vote
but let's look at the data we're going
to compare three
important states michigan pennsylvania
and wisconsin
those are three states that trump won in
2016. and we're going to look at how
hillary was doing 22 days before the
election
compared to how biden is doing so let's
start in michigan
in michigan at this point in 2016
hillary was winning by 10.7
while today biden is winning by only
seven so hillary's lead at this point
in michigan was bigger than biden's
today and what happened in the end in
michigan
trump won by 0.3 in pennsylvania
we had joe biden today we have joe biden
today with essentially the same lead
that hillary had in 2016. it's a
difference of
less than half a point and in the end in
2016
donald trump won in pennsylvania by just
under one point then we have wisconsin
and in wisconsin joe biden currently
leads by 6.1
that is a smaller lead than hillary's
at this point in 2016 and again
that is a state that ultimately was won
by donald trump
why does this matter it matters because
even if biden gets a larger popular vote
victory than donald trump
on the wings of massive victories in
large blue states like california
new york as examples he can still lose
electorally if he loses
these states case in point if we look at
average polling right now and look at a
sort of consensus map
in which we give joe biden nevada and
north carolina which we don't know that
biden will win but
give by nevada give biden north carolina
and we
simply leave out for the moment the
three states we're talking about
and florida that gets joe biden
257 electoral votes that's 13
shy of the number he needs if in that
scenario
biden wins michigan or pennsylvania or
any two of the three states michigan
wisconsin pennsylvania
then biden no longer needs florida at
all and biden wins
but if joe biden ends up losing these
three states that we're talking about
wisconsin michigan and pennsylvania all
of a sudden
the entire election comes down to
florida and florida alone
which did not go well in 2016 for
hillary clinton
now of course you can say come on david
the polling won't be wrong in all of
those states
i certainly hope not but remember the
polling tightened in the last two weeks
the the exercise today is if we look at
biden today in wisconsin michigan and
pennsylvania
compared to hillary 22 days out
four years ago biden is not doing as
well as hillary was doing
at that point of course the polling
tightened
so the point here is when it's this
close
the confidence does nothing for us we
just have to know
that these states look okay for biden
right now they looked
better for hillary in 2016 and she lost
those states and subsequently the
election
which is why our conclusion from all of
this beautiful academic exercise here
but the conclusion is we can do nothing
other than vote in every state
as if it's 50 50 and our vote my vote
your vote could be the vote that decides
your
state if you game it out that is the
only
rational approach to this election i
hope that is the approach you are going
to be adapt adopting
so over the long weekend donald trump
pulled a stunt
where i guess to prove how healthy he is
and how wonderfully
everything is going with his coronavirus
case in advance of restarting rallies
and town halls and maybe debates which
he did
already he staged a so-called medical
exam on fox news
now it really was not actually an exam
it was a conversation with that same fox
news doctor mark siegel
who a couple of months ago did an
interview with trump about his cognitive
state
and said trump was amazing his cognitive
state is just stunning
this medical exam which wasn't a medical
exam
is hilarious because if you listen to
donald trump he doesn't answer
a single question we learned nothing
during this entire interview other than
by process of elimination
that at the time of this interview
donald trump was still positive for
coronavirus
that's all we learned during this fake
medical exam
so let's get into it trump is asked
about
symptoms and basically says nothing
other than he didn't feel
strong and insists he had no breathing
issues that you had
last friday like when you went into
walter reed what were the two most
prominent symptoms that
you had i think didn't feel strong
didn't feel really strong i didn't have
a problem with breathing
which a lot of people seemed to have i
had none of that
but i didn't feel very strong i didn't
feel very vital
i didn't feel like the president of the
u.s should feel
and i knew there was something a little
bit off and the doctors at walter reed
were incredible
we've known for a week though that trump
was given
oxygen at least once and probably
multiple times
and there were numerous reports about
trouble breathing but again
asked what were your symptoms a
seemingly straightforward question
trump doesn't name any but you'll see in
the next question that all of a sudden
symptoms start to crop up next question
is were you scared
and trump lists medications he got were
you scared were you frightened
well i took the regeneron and eli lilly
makes a similar very similar medicine
but you have regenerate you have the eli
lilly version of it and it just
within a period of 24 hours i felt very
different i think i could have left the
hospital a lot earlier
but it made a tremendous difference mark
and uh
you know markedly so and and uh i just
felt very good
it it uh you would have sort of a sore
throat
just to add to what we were saying but
but i felt
really very very good after taking this
for
a period of time it's a transfusion not
a shot
reports actually are that trump was
panicking as his symptoms started
and started asking people at the white
house if he was going to die
like his friend who died of coronavirus
but notice that
trump then adds a symptom there i guess
he forgot before he says well you know i
did have a sore throat
when he was asked about symptoms he said
i didn't really have anything other than
i didn't feel super strong
so okay we've added a symptom trump is
then
asked about medications and this is so
funny
i think trump just doesn't understand
anything i think he's just not a
particularly bright guy
he says he's not taking any medications
right now
but mentions that like eight hours ago
he did take medications take a look at
this
thing and uh right now i'm uh
medication free i'm not taking any
medications as of
you know probably eight hours ago or so
i'm medication free
which frankly makes me feel good i don't
like medication
so trump seems confused about his own
medication regimen he says well
as of eight out in the last eight hours
i've taken nothing well
have you finished courses of those
medications
because if you take something daily
there's a point in the day where you
could say listen
it's been 23 hours since i took anything
well but are you
off the medications or have you just not
taken your next dose yet
bizarre way of answering every single
question
trump later asked again about
medications
and now he sounds completely different
he says i
think really i'm not taking anything and
we are
pretty much finished with medications
which is not the same as
i am no longer on anything take a look
at this
what are you taking right now as of
today i think really nothing
uh we pretty much finished
and now we'll see how things go but
pretty much nothing uh
we had our uh final doses of just about
everything actually the tr the original
transfusion
that's supposed to last for about four
months so trump is
pretty much taking no medication and
basically had his last doses
just a few hours earlier like does he
even understand his own
treatment i had a conversation with some
friends over the weekend where we were
talking about
we talked specifically about this
interview which we had all seen
and we were kind of arguing about is
trump here
being strategically vague on purpose
when he answers these questions
or does he not really understand what's
going on
and whether he's taking medications or
or like his own treatment
and the consensus was it could be a
little bit of this a little bit of that
then donald trump is asked about well
what medical tests did you have
did you have a cat scan trump doesn't
seem to know
what he had take a look you would feel
comfortable can you tell me a little bit
about the tests you had in the hospital
did you have a cat scan what did that
show
yeah they tested the lungs they have
incredible equipment at
walter reed in fact
they said no you could leave your jacket
on that's the first that's ever happened
leave your shirt on leave your jacket on
i said i'll take it off anyway if you
want
but literally they tested the lungs they
checked for the lungs and they
tested it with different machinery they
have incredible stuff that i've never
even seen before
and uh it tested it tested good
initially i think they had some
congestion
in there uh but it tested ultimately it
tested
good and with each day it got better and
i think that's why they wanted me to
stay
frankly but the cat scans were amazing
the equipment was incredible i've never
seen equipment like this before
the cat scans were amazing imagine that
and of course
tests like no one's ever seen before i
like that he says they checked for the
lungs
they did find the lungs there reportedly
according to the scans they did they did
find
trump's lungs and medical experts are
unanimous trump
the lungs were there as far as trump is
concerned
but it all tested good congestion in the
lungs may be who knows
it's not clear whether trump actually
means what the medical term
lung congestion means or whether trump
means he was stuffed up in his nose
which of course would be
another another symptom he had not
explained recently
it's all wacky and then the big question
of course that many of us were waiting
for
have you been tested and are you
negative the answer is a pretzel
it's a verbal inkblot take a look at
this are you tested i heard you i heard
you said you were going to test again
today
have you been retested uh i have
been retested and i haven't even found
out numbers or anything yet but i've
been retested
and i know i'm at either the bottom of
the scale or free
when is your next test going to be i
don't know probably tomorrow mark they
test every
couple of days i guess but uh it's
really at a level now that's been uh
great great to see it disappear so i
haven't gotten the numbers
but i'm at the bottom of the scale or
free
and he's at a great level when it comes
to the virus
are you positive or negative for
coronavirus
obviously if he was negative at the time
he would have said it
if you look at the letter put out by his
doctor just a few hours later you will
noticeably see
that trump tested negative is missing
from the letter the letter says trump
meets criteria
to stop isolation he's no longer a
transmission risk
he's been fever free for more than 24
hours
there's no longer evidence of actively
replicating
virus trump has decreasing viral loads
no mention of trump tested negative for
kovid and you can bet your ass that if
he attested negative they would be
saying it
ultimately we learned or were told
that trump tested negative literally on
route on a plane
to a mass rally in florida last night
which we will talk about a little later
but as you can see
trump cleared by his doctor to return to
public events and campaigning
and indeed he did and we will get to
that later
make sure you're following me on twitter
i'm d pakman on twitter
what do you make of this bizarre
supposed medical exam
which was a doctor asking trump
questions
that he didn't even answer let me know
what you make of it on twitter we'll be
back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches
from top quality materials and they just
look great
i went on their site and picked out a
watch from their icon
automatic collection the one i got is in
mesh matte black
and i love it it's simple sleek elegant
goes great with just about
anything i'm wearing and i've gotten a
ton of compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that website memberships are
the
primary way we fund the david pakman
show
grab a membership at joinpackman.com
we're going to discuss how coronavirus
cases are
once again exploding nationally
hitting records in 13 states but before
we do that
in that context we have to talk about a
coveted positive republican senator
not just a senator who doesn't think
covet is a threat understand but this is
a guy who has coronavirus
was at the first day of hearings for amy
coney barrett's nomination to the
supreme court
speaking with no mask i'm talking about
the utah republican senator mike lee
mike lee was one of these
three senators who tested positive in
trump's orbit
last week or so along with north
carolina's tom tillis
and wisconsin's senator ron
johnson so mike lee tested positive for
coronavirus wearing
no mask yesterday at the hearings while
speaking so in this first picture
if you're watching you see mike lee on
your left with a mask the mask is not
fully covering his nose
next to lindsey graham and right above
the head of 87 year old senator chuck
grassley
mike lee has coronavirus he tested
positive 10 days ago
he's there for some reason speaking over
the head of an 87 year old all right
then during the hearing here is recently
covered positive mike lee
speaking with no mascon in an enclosed
room
stunning stuff right now some of you
will say
oh well he's probably not contagious
anymore
is that the defense he probably isn't
contagious because it's been 10 days
he's in a room full of old people having
tested positive 10 days ago with no mask
why chance it
why not just keep the mask on because
you tested
positive 10 days ago they don't care
and even when wearing the mask it's not
a license to be on top of people
he's on top of 87 year old chuck
grassley who by the way
also doesn't seem to care too much about
the threat of coronavirus
of course that's his problem if it's of
his own doing but understand
what mike lee is currently doing in the
united states senate which is
he's at a large gathering in a confined
indoor space without a mask
after testing positive for covet 19
that's illegal in a lot of countries
even in many states i mean in oregon and
massive you you
you're not allowed to do what he's doing
it wouldn't be a lot you wouldn't be
allowed in a grocery store
in canada with what mike lee is doing
and he's in the u.s senate around nearly
90 year old men
i hear a lot of comments like these guys
are pricks
that's a term maybe when someone cuts
you off in line at the supermarket
somebody takes the parking spot you're
waiting for and had your blinker
uh pointing to maybe that's a prick okay
this is a guy who tested positive for
coronavirus
speaking without a mask in a room with
people nearly
90 years of age it's monstrous
it's almost bio-terrorism now everybody
calm down i'm not saying it is
bio-terrorism but it is
almost bio-terrorism he's choosing to
endanger others
he could have skyped in as some senators
did he could have at least kept the mask
on the entire time as other people did
he could
reduce the risk of transmission by
keeping the mask
on because remember he tested positive
for coronavirus this is not the vague
well you know maybe i'm asymptomatic and
don't know
he tested positive for the virus but
again
trump is starting rallies trump had a
rally last night with people crowded
together
even the people on the stage behind
trump weren't all wearing masks at
another one of these super spreader
events so
look at the examples that are being set
mike lee setting an example for the
people at trump's rally
the people at trump's rallies setting
examples for what people
republicans in the senate are doing it's
a complete and total mess
and by the way and this is what we'll
talk about next
the the virus is surging again and let's
go right into the numbers
i don't know if folks are aware but
we have to keep covering it coronavirus
cases have exploded again
with the most cases in the united states
in two months and new records
in 13 states now i know that the
republican party and the trump
administration
and the trump campaign are acting as if
it's over as if nothing's going on
we saw covet positive republican senator
mike lee
taking his mask off indoors around 80
year olds at yesterday's amy coney
barrett
supreme court hearings trump is doing
rallies again
but we do have a pandemic going on and
it's not going so well the latest
numbers are that on october 9th so
that's a friday
i think friday saturday friday over the
weekend
we had just shy of 61 000 new cases in
one day that's the most new cases in a
single day dating back
almost two months to august 14th as you
probably
know by now deaths lag cases by two to
three weeks
we've now seen what was a declining
death trend
level off it's now flat and in all
likelihood it's already happened twice
before
during this pandemic when cases spike
deaths spike
two to three weeks later that's at the
national level
now there are 13 states most of them in
the western midwest
that have new records for coronavirus
infections over the last week these are
seven day rolling averages which is a
better indicator than just a single day
new seven day rolling average highs in
alaska
colorado indiana minnesota montana
nebraska new mexico north dakota ohio
oklahoma oregon south dakota and
wisconsin the worst of which
are in montana new mexico and south
dakota now you might come in and say oh
but
but but but david clucking like a
chicken
what about hospitalizations well indiana
north dakota montana and nebraska
reporting record high numbers of
coronavirus hospitalizations
on sunday same with utah so
hospitalizations are going up so
understand that no matter how many times
trump says
it's disappearing instead of we've
turned the corner he says we rounded the
turn
i understand he's trying to say we turn
the corner 13 out of 50 states have new
record highs
that's new peaks in more than a quarter
of american states and even in states
that aren't at new highs numbers are
climbing i mean look
even here in massachusetts for example
we were down to about 150 cases per day
for months
we've now once again started to get into
the 300 cases per day in september
400 cases per day at the end of
september 600 case days
in october so far so it is coming back
exactly as predicted
it's not just flu season we have college
students
flying around the country and spreading
we have schools
a number of schools having to very
quickly shut things down
and also that people are exhausted which
i understand
not everybody is being as careful even
people who were being more careful
at a certain point meanwhile trump's
back to doing rallies if you can believe
that and we will be talking about that
in a little bit difficult situation
because we must vote
like our lives depend on it and yet
cases are rising
and we want to be safe we are seeing
record lines at early voting we'll have
the numbers for early voting
on today's bonus show people mostly
wearing masks
orders of magnitude more early votes
this year than in 2016. that's great
we have to have a plan to vote i will be
dropping off my absentee
ballot i think this week in person at
city hall
received it last week i'm ready to go i
will film
myself dropping it off and post it as
part of my
get out the vote effort so let us know
we'll have a question on our instagram
about what is your plan
for voting we are at david pakman show
on instagram
and if you want to see this is a great
break from politics if you want a
two-minute break from politics
i harvested my tomatoes yesterday in
advance of the frost
and it is stunning what i was able to
get from just
three small tomato bushes okay uh
david.pakman on instagram
take a two minute break from politics
check out my produce
my friends and we'll be back right after
this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
over the last few years fox business
host maria bartiromo
has become increasingly sycophantic when
it comes to donald trump
each interview she gives him is easier
and easier
never questioning his ludicrous and
outrageous ideas and his claims
and we have another interview with her
from this weekend and it couldn't have
gone worse and what's very funny to see
is that
although her interviews get easier and
easier for trump
trump figures out a way to do even more
poorly
regardless of how easy the interview is
donald trump
seems both to have recovered from
coronavirus and be sicker than ever
in a certain way we're going to go
through this one and really think about
what it means for our country that this
is the president of the united states
trump kicking things off with the most
powerful topic you can
imagine trump urges the media
to cover the fact that joe biden coughed
the day before take a look at this
i really don't i don't believe it and
speaking about joe biden
if you look at joe he was coughing
yesterday horribly
and grabbing his mask as he's coughing
and speaking and grabbing his mask and
coughing
and i don't know what that was all about
and it didn't get much pressed because
the press doesn't do that
but he was coughing yesterday quite
badly i must tell you and
it was not a good thing to watch and and
as he's coughing he's grabbing his mask
with his fingers
so you may want to look into that too so
that's that right a very very powerful
critique of joe biden
trump asked about the florida rally from
last night
maria bartoromo knowing that trump
planned to do a rally last night which
he did which we'll cover later
saying what are you going to do to keep
people safe from coronavirus at your
rally
and trump answers merely by talking
about himself look
i want you to answer your critics
because your critics are
uh going uh really uh betting upset
about your
event at the white house yesterday about
your rally that you're planning tomorrow
they say it is still too soon for you to
be around people and to be going out
that you could still spread covid what
are you doing
in terms of ensuring that everyone will
be safe at your rally in florida
this week tomorrow well the doctors the
white house doctors as you know
are the best and they said totally
free of spreading there's no spread and
it wasn't yesterday either and by the
way i don't know if you noticed i was on
a balcony the closest person was
probably a couple of hundred feet away
and they were down and on grass there
was nobody even close to me yesterday
but even yesterday i knew i was uh free
what will you do to keep
people safe i have great doctors i'm not
going to spread this thing and trump
doesn't
he's so narcissistically delusional that
he doesn't seem to get the concern
isn't just are you going to give the
virus to someone
it's you're packing people together with
very few masks
and they're going to give it to each
other it doesn't even enter into trump's
way of thinking
trump then claims to have a protective
glow
now that he has had coronavirus
uh we i passed the highest test the
highest standards
and i'm in great shape and i have to
tell you i feel fantastically i really
feel good and
i even feel good by the fact that you
know the word immunity means something
having
uh having uh really a protective
glow means something i think it's very
important to have that
to have that is a very important thing
yeah the trump's just radioactive from
the virus ladies and gentlemen
um trump then tried to talk policy
this is where you really see how trump's
cognition
is is suffering it has declined he is
completely unable to talk about
policy trump just wildly says as soon as
we win
everybody gets a middle income tax cut
but at this point does anybody believe
it
come people we're giving a middle-income
tax cut
very soon as soon as we win we're giving
a middle income tax cut it'll be a very
substantial middle income tax cut
and i've already done this as soon as i
win
i give out a tax cut well why do you
need
to win why not do it now or why didn't
you already do it well i've already done
it wait so
if you've already done it why are you
doing it again
incoherent no detail just like
i i must remind you in august
donald trump was interviewed by chris
wallace in that interview
donald trump said in two weeks we are
signing
a new health care system into law that
was in early august
two weeks have come and gone four weeks
have come and gone eight weeks have now
come and gone
whatever happened to that health care
bill we don't know
trump then again completely unable to
answer this question he's now gotten
four five six times what is your agenda
for the second term the answer
it's beyond parody you can't satirize
the answer because there is no answer
back in february what do you want to do
in terms of your policies in a second
term sir
well the first thing we have to do marie
is open up our country you can't keep
all these states closed up the democrat
states
and they're not doing well and the
country is doing well we're looking like
a super v
but uh you know despite the fact new
york has to open up new york's like a
ghost town new york is very sad what's
going on there and
and other places we just want a case in
michigan
against the governor the governor that
is you know the i call
the complainer in chief all she does is
complain except when she's on the phone
directly all she does is say thank you
very much for doing such a great job
what's your platform for the second term
open the country during a pandemic
everything's great though but democrats
are bad new york is sad
michigan is bad wait so what what's your
second term policy i'm confused
there is none ladies and gentlemen then
in the middle of the interview
it's almost a non-sequitur it gets weird
maria bartoromo
asks donald trump are there ufos and
trump again it's beyond parody trump
says he's going to look into that very
strongly
take a look at this mr president as we
wrap up here are there ufos
well i'm gonna have to check on that i
mean i've heard that i heard that two
days ago so i'll check on that
i'll take a good strong look at that but
i will tell you this uh
we now have created a military the likes
of which we've never had before in terms
of equipment
the the equipment that we have the
weapons that we have
trump's going to take a good strong
hearty look
at whether there are ufos but
what he's sure of is he loves the
military industrial complex bragging
about all the guns and weapons that he's
purchased and then to close out the
interview to round it out
the president calls the fbi scum
and maria bartoromo says okay as she's
trying to wrap up the interview
and the fbi look the greatest people in
the world are in the fbi but the top
people were
scum absolute scum and they did a
horrible job for our country
mr president we so appreciate your time
this morning thank you very much sir
president donald j trump the fbi are
scum
thank you so much for being here mr
president so
the interviews get easier and easier
these are supposed to be
gotchas i'm sorry gimmies for donald
trump just
easy you know like a two foot putt which
i don't know if trump can make a two
foot putt he cheats at golf too but
it's supposed to be like the proverbial
two-foot putt uh and
trump just can't do it he can't do it
and taking
a page out of his notebook is his son
eric trump who himself was interviewed
over the weekend
and that's what i want to talk about
next most of you probably know that eric
trump
is not exactly the one we typically
refer to as the smart one
but he even outdid himself in a
completely wacky interview
on abc on sunday with jonathan carl now
eric trump was interviewed i guess as a
surrogate of the trump administration or
a surrogate of the trump campaign i
think better said fine
but as you watch this i want you to
understand and consider
that the importance of beating trump
this election this november
it's not just about preventing trump
from being president for another four
years
so that the country doesn't go
completely off a cliff another reason
why
we must defeat trump this november is
that
if we don't in 2024 i guarantee it
either eric or don jr or ivanka are
going to have a leg up
in the republican primary for president
in 2024
at some point one of them runs and i
believe that if trump gets another four
years
you will see at least the possibility of
an attempt at one of his kids running
and this interview should be a reminder
as to why we need to stop that
at absolutely all costs we know that the
republican electorate is really ignorant
they aren't going to stop the trump kids
so we need to prevent them from getting
a running start
by trump getting another four years in
november so let's get into the clips
eric trump
on this week uh again you know he's
supposedly just a businessman at this
point
but he's there as a surrogate of the
trump campaign doesn't really make sense
but he's there and he is
mad that the media will accurately
report
when trump does these mass rallies it
risks spreading the virus take a look at
this
i mean they took every precaution again
temperature checks mass they were
outside
it was a beautiful event um sure but why
is it that it's only trump events that
are called out
why why are these protests that we see
all over the place i see them in new
york i see them in portland i see them
in seattle
i see them everywhere antifa is going
wild and no one ever talks about them
wearing masks but yet a beautiful
protest by african americans and
hispanic americans
in front of the white house to support
our incredible men and women
in law enforcement becomes the subject
of an abc
show at 9 00 a.m on a sunday morning i
mean it it
well well eric eric to be clear i'm not
i've been i've lost a lot of faith in
the media john i really have
well eric to be clear i'm not
criticizing and i'm reporting
the fact he's totally incoherent what is
he even talking about
these mass events do have the potential
to be super spreader events
period and the fact that the media is
covering them as such
is because the media is doing a good job
of course he's not pleased with it
eric trump then admits that trump is
having rallies at the white house now
this is problematic for two reasons
trump has been playing coy and saying
these are peaceful protests
because if you call it a protest it's
okay if you call it a rally it's a
problem
but it's also a problem because you're
not supposed to use the white house
for political campaigning and by calling
it a rally
eric trump again nobody said maybe he
says
i've never claimed eric trump is the
smart one but he's admitting that these
are rallies at the white house
and you know this you report from every
single day everybody that goes within uh
you know 500 yards of the the white
house is tested every single day and
it's a little bit of a different
apparatus
you know in in that machine but again i
just find it i find the hypocrisy so
crazy i mean you go out there and you
see these massive
massive riots and protests in these
liberal-run cities and no one's wearing
mass and no one cares no one cares
the media doesn't talk about them i mean
how many have we had in new york and how
many have we had in chicago and all
these things and
the media never talks about that but
again when you have a peaceful trump
um you know rally at the white house in
support of law enforcement by
african-americans cnn cuts away
you know msnbc cuts away from those
events they don't truly the rantings of
someone completely disconnected from
reality he really seems to think
that he and his family are just the
biggest victims out there
they're martyrs they've agreed to be the
first family
to despite what would be best for them
in order to just make things better for
everybody and everybody attacks them of
course
the big differences include that
everyone is wearing masks at the various
protests that's why they don't seem to
have spread the virus
eric trump who is clearly not an expert
in any of these matters then goes on to
talk about donald trump
taking a vaccine now it's false that
as far as we know trump didn't get a
vaccine
during his treatment for coronavirus he
got medications
but not vaccines and certainly donald
trump has done nothing
in terms of creating a vaccine but eric
trump bizarrely says here
donald trump took a vaccine and the
interviewer
jonathan carl can't believe what he's
hearing take a listen to this
the guy sounded 100 it was amazing it
actually probably goes to speak to how
good some of these vaccines that are
being created are and
what my father's done on the vaccine
front no one could have done no one
could have done i mean
literally i didn't was calling my father
xenophobic for shutting down
america from from travel to china i mean
and the virus came from china
my father literally started day one
creating this vaccine he
worked to push this vaccine and now my
father just took it
and uh you see how well he got over it
wait wait wait can you i think he's an
inspiration i think
as american jean we should be very proud
of that can you clarify that you said
your father just took a vaccine
meaning when he was in walter reed the
medicines that he was taking and
the therapeutics he felt horrible and
and on on saturday
again i spoke to the man three times on
saturday and he sounded tremendous and i
think it goes to show the power of you
know medicine and
um in this country and how how far that
you know that we've come on covid in the
last uh you know six seven months
vaccines cured my dad
which my dad created
joe biden being xenophobic what
what my father took a vaccine
huh what does it make any sense
is eric trump now there's a there's one
idea which is
eric trump let slip that trump has
received a vaccine but they're not going
public
i just think eric trump's dumb i don't
think he's letting anything slip here
eric trump then was asked about the fact
that donald trump called kamala harris a
monster
and eric trump of course defends it this
is funny
vice president pence when he debated
kamala harris he said it was a privilege
to be on the stage with her
uh recognized her history making uh pick
as
as biden's running mate and then the
next day your father said that she was
a monster what why yeah how how is
kamal harris a monster why why did he
say that
well you know i think there are a lot of
the chances that she takes that are just
they're the mind-boggling to me i mean
she's come out and she's called to
abolish law enforcement she's you know
compared
members of of ice to the kkk in a
congressional hearing
uh she wants to take away 180 million
private health care plans in this
country
um last week she was coming out talking
about how she literally she wanted to
limit the amount of red meat that
americans could eat i mean i
would but but eric but eric eric eric
political differences and i think you've
mischaracterized
her positions in that litany but
political differences are one thing a
monster
you're calling the democratic vice
presidential
nominee a monster your father did how is
that
i mean i i don't i don't get it john you
know you're also dealing with a person
who's willing to lie every single day
you know it's amazing one day
they're calling for the let's kamala
harris and frankly joe biden but
i love that when eric trump says you're
dealing with someone who's willing to
lie every day jonathan carl says who
it's a completely kafka-esque moment
that's not i don't know that we've ever
used the term kafkaesque
on this program before it is a
completely surreal kafka-esque moment
eric when eric says you're dealing with
someone who's willing to lie every day
jonathan carl is confused because
there's no bigger liar in politics right
now than donald trump
i guess eric was talking about joe biden
or kamala harris but a completely
wild moment also he's lying by saying
kamala wants to abolish police that's
hilarious she doesn't in fact people are
some people on the left don't like
kamala because she doesn't want to
abolish police
she doesn't want to take anybody's
health care and then eric trump
ends this interview which didn't go well
claiming that it's a lie that we know
who all of donald trump's creditors are
and you can tell he's particularly
triggered by this one because he starts
speed
talking and making even less sense than
he had been making throughout the
interview
the media has become the the activist
arm for the democratic party
eric nothing's fair eric we're eric
we're asking we're asking legitimate
questions one last one the new york
times report also
said that the president owes some 400
million dollars
don't the american people have a right
to know who he is indebted to
who the president of the united states
owes money to can you clarify that for
us
jonathan his financial disclosures you
know exactly who the money's owed to
that's that's another democratic talking
point that you just
you know exactly who the money's okay my
father's i don't billions of dollars
and and on a proportion of his net worth
my father has very very very low
leverage in fact the new york times if
you want to bring them into this
they came out and said that the other
day if you own if you own buildings if
you own real estate you you carry some
debt
that's that's what developers do that's
what business owners do they carry some
debt
now as a proportion of his net worth
it's incredibly low we have a phenomenal
company but there's there's nothing new
about that and by the way it's the same
debt that he got elected on
and it's all fully disclosed as
financial disclosure forms
government that you have access to eric
eric thank you for joining us i
appreciate your time on this sunday
morning thank you we have a phenomenal
company
he says that lost money
so that we could get tax breaks but it's
a great company
it just happens to be in direct conflict
with what we learn
about the profitability of the company
through the bombshell new york tax
report new york times tax report which
said
the business actually was a disaster
many years
painful to listen to and again he's
there
eric trump is as a surrogate for the
campaign
although he supposedly has no role in
anything government or campaign related
he's merely an independent businessman
can you make any more sense out of it
than i can and do you agree with me
that of the three adult trump children
ivanka don jr and eric
eric's by far the worst in these
interviews let me know if you agree
disagree
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio
and video streams of the show just for
members
sign up today at joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
it might shock you to hear this but
donald trump is back to doing rallies he
was shot out of a cannon
yesterday rampant speculation that
donald trump is still under the
influence of steroids because he did see
manic and i have to tell you
i have never seen donald trump speak
this quickly or
act as manically or maniacally
choose which one you like as he did last
night but we will get to that
because first i have to set the context
for you donald trump
who reportedly only first tested
negative for coronavirus
since having it on the flight to
sanford florida did a mass rally
yesterday
in the state of florida which is you can
see if you're watching along with me
very few masks even on the stage behind
donald trump
essentially no masks among the crowd
not on the stage right behind him they
do not care
much the same way that trump's rallies
aren't
politics they're more like sporting
events
trump's crowds are not connected to the
reality of a global pandemic it is not
just some of their ideas
that are in the 1950s their
uh day-to-day is nine months
stale from when we didn't have a
pandemic usually at least
the people on the screen behind tr on
the stage who are on screen behind trump
are told you have to wear masks here
more than half of the people even on
stage visible behind trump didn't have
masks on
and then before we get into some of the
specifics just a little bit about the
atmospherics
aside from the barely any masks
situation
and no social distancing whatsoever
florida republican governor ron desantis
was at the rally
without a mask high-fiving rally goers
touching everybody's hands we have video
of it that we've been
showing our audience as if once again
there's been no global pandemic raging
for the last eight months now you really
have to see it to believe it
so that's the context in which this
rally is happening
maskless republican governor high-fiving
people
no social distancing very few masks a
recently coveted positive president
delivering a speech now on to the speech
donald trump appeared completely manic
now the speculation of course
is that it's still the dexamethasone or
or simply
that trump was given a steroid so that
he would have more energy for the rally
he did seem tired towards the end
struggling more to project his voice and
breathe but he was out of control
trump again alluding to the consequences
of crimes that still have not yet been
enumerated by obama biden and hillary
bizarre dystopian authoritarian moment
take a look
because we are doing more for this
country
than any administration has ever done
despite the witch hunts and the phony
stuff that we caught them on now we
caught them cold and we'll see what
happens with that
just watch stay tuned so of course this
is completely
authoritarian strong man trump last week
said
that joe biden should be indicted and
trump still has not been able to tell us
what laws were broken by barack obama by
joe biden by hillary clinton
the crowd doesn't care the crowd loves
it trump then referred to his campaign
as a campon
in another one of these verbal glitches
and you'll see this one take
shape uh very quickly we achieved all of
this despite the fact
that we caught them cold they were
spying on our camp
it's our campaign it's our campaign not
my campaign trump did that thing there
where his brain realizes that what's
coming out of his mouth
doesn't make any sense so he sort of
just stops short and restarts a
different
sentence we've seen it happen at this
time at this point dozens and dozens of
times
trump then again with this entire
we're going to take care of them after
the election
horribly authoritarian and it actually
leads to chance of lock them up again
sort of a staple of the trump rally
calling for the jailing without due
process
of trump's political adversaries take a
look
but we'll take care of it all after the
election we caught him called
we caught him called bad people crooked
hillary
and by the way obama and biden knew
everything that was happening okay just
in case you had any questions
we'll take care of it after the election
joe biden and the democrat socialist but
that gives you another reason to go out
and vote we got to get in
because we don't they'll just sweep it
under the rug
you also hear in addition to lock them
up
trump again referring to biden as a
socialist
we had a good phone call about this last
week from someone saying
during live calls a young lady called in
and said listen my family believes joe
biden's a socialist when i try to talk
to them
to them about the election they say the
joe biden's a socialist he's her
family's cuban we're going to be like
cuba it's going to be a castro again and
i don't know what to say when they say
that
whenever someone says biden is socialist
the first question
must be which socialist policies
are is biden advocating for usually that
will short-circuit
like 95 you know 19 out of 20 of those
diatribes and they'll move on to
something else it because the answer is
obviously biden is not advocating for
any socialist policies
much to the chagrin of actual socialists
who want a further left democratic
presidential candidate but doesn't
matter
facts don't matter all that matters is
feelings
at trump's rally trump then taking his
anger out on the media here he is saying
that the media
are the sickest of them all these people
are the sickest of them all have
[Applause]
you know uh turning an entire crowd
against reporters and camera people in
the back of the room
is is very strong man dictator-ish it
really is and i'm sure you all know that
and then this moment totally wild
trump saying he feels so good and again
this could be the steroids talking
dexamethasone and other steroids can
make you euphoric
trump's saying he feels so damn good
that
covid trump wants to go into the
audience
and kiss the men and the attractive
women take a look at this
but if you want to get out there get out
one thing with me the nice part
i went through it now they say i'm
immune i can feel i feel so powerful
i'll
walk into that audience i'll walk in
there i'll kiss everyone in that
audience
i'll kiss the guys and the beautiful
women and um
everybody i'll just give you a big fat
kiss
no but there is something nice i don't
have to be locked up in my basement and
i wouldn't allow that to happen anyway
so that's trump's manic upper voice
which we've come to recognize it's at a
12
since he's been on whatever medications
he's been on for coronavirus trump
continuing to mock
joe biden by the way for having safe
events
trump ridiculing biden while he has he
being trump has super spreader events
you know these are the real polls so
when did you hear about this meeting
like a day ago
these are the real pulse right
[Applause]
the other guy gets out there and he's
they work and work and work and 30
people show up they put them in those
crazy circles right
they only have the circles because
that's the only way they can fill up the
room it's true
trump himself appears to have caught
coronavirus
at an event he organized at the white
house for amy coney barrett
and he's laughing at joe biden he
laughed at him during the debate for
wearing masks
he's now laughing at joe biden for
having small socially distant campaign
events
and the crowd just loves it the crowd is
cheering the guy who caught coronavirus
at one of his own events
for saying the other guy's events
aren't full of people during a pandemic
it's backwards everything that's
happening is completely backwards
and uh there was a i'm not going to play
the clip for you
for this this next clip but there was
another hilariously ignorant moment
during the rally where if you watched
behind trump there were people with
blacks for trump
shirts there were people with latinos
for trump shirts there were some puerto
rico
shirts puerto ricans for trump and trump
said at one point puerto rico better
vote for me
now of course puerto rico doesn't vote
in the presidential election because
it's
not a state i would love for puerto rico
to be a state
many on the left would love for puerto
rico to be a state trump
still confused about puerto rico even at
this late stage in the game
these rallies are going to continue this
week i'll be covering both
trump and biden events this week also an
update debate number two was scheduled
for thursday
when the commission on presidential
debates said we'll do it virtual because
trump has coveted
trump said no then the debate has been
canceled altogether the latest is that
joe biden will be doing a 90-minute town
hall
and that trump is pursuing a competing
town hall we don't know if it will be
back to back on different networks at
the same time on different networks
i don't know but i'm here we are here
through election day so i will be
covering
whatever it is that ultimately happens
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p here's a really
interesting question and and i do
actually have a lot to say about it and
there's actually a lot going on in the
progressive media space with this
take a listen to this okay hey david
this is josh in north texas
i know you've been doing some life
prepping over the last several months
and i'm wondering what sort of
prep preparations you're making for
the election just in case things go
south
afterward have a good day well listen i
i don't want to say too much
but the truth is that i
and there are other progressive hosts
who not
not just because of the election
upcoming and fears of violence but
there this might i'm not gonna mention
anybody i don't want to blow up
anybody's spot
there are multiple progressive hosts i
know
who publicly live in one
part of the country but they don't
actually live there they actually their
lives are actually somewhere else
and they're doing it specifically
because of some of the fears of violence
all i will say is certainly
the situation post-election regardless
of the results it could get very very
ugly um i at this point
have multiple duplicate studios they
they look the same
okay you can't tell from looking where
which studio i'm in i've actually come
to you
from a variety of locations over the
last couple of months
and there is contingency planning going
on i mean i guess it's not
i don't i don't think anybody would
would find it crazy given the
circumstances to say that
now from the standpoint of my basic
prepping coronavirus prepping
you know i've gotten the basic things my
my cars now have uh you know first aid
kits and
changes of clothes and and basic
survival elements as the case may be
i've got water storage going we had a
brown water incident at my place a few
months ago where
i had to boil water for like a period of
six hours i'm storing water now i've got
water ready to go it's a beautiful thing
but i don't have like years of food i've
not become mormon you know i don't have
years of food storage
or anything like that but certainly a
lot of interesting conversations
happening
within the independent progressive media
space
over the last period of time i will say
to quote donald trump
we have a great bonus show for you today
we are going to talk about the number of
people that have already voted this year
compared to last election it is crazy
the difference number two we will talk
about the michigan domestic terror plot
which has really sent shockwaves both
through the militia world and through
the world of people who want uh
peace in our country and we will also
talk about how
solar now when you actually back out
the way that fossil fuels are subsidized
solar
is becoming the cheapest electricity on
the planet and we will talk about that
in more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member
joinpacman.com is the place to do it
we have a coupon code 2020 now
which will save you 66 if you so choose
i will see you on the bonus show
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's program
was made possible by vincero
watches the american watchmaker building
super quality wrist watches but
making them affordable for everyday
people and they're giving you 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero
today's show also sponsored by blinkist
blinkist is the app that lets you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in 15 minutes and you can try blinkist
for free and get 25 off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put that link down
below
underneath the video